chef jeff with smith's food and drugs
the sponsors of this segment welcomes in
guest chef lacey nixon for a quick
lesson on how to cook the perfect
southern collard greens in honor of
black history month
hello everybody i'm chef jeff from
smith's okay i'm really excited about
today's episode it's black history month
and to celebrate that i have lacey nixon
here with me a colleague of mine she's
going to make collard greens for us it's
a traditional dish go ahead and explain
to us what you're going to do so today
i'm going to be doing collard greens
which it has a soft spot in my heart
because my grandmother inspired me to
cook
she taught me all the steps and i've
done it for years now i use it at
gatherings for family and i usually
always try and make it for black history
month um
great opportunity
let's get right to it so first of all
we're going to take our greens which we
have our collard and mustard green mix
you can actually get these at your local
smiths they come in
16 ounce bags as you see right over
there very convenient to have and then
we have so i like to do half half of the
the green mix and then i'll do ham shank
which you can cut it up cubed you can
also give that at your local smiths in
your meat department do about half of
that
followed by the other half of the greens
put that in there so it's kind of
everything in the poll absolutely so
apologies they take time to cook right
absolutely now this it depends on what
you're using i like to use a pressure
cooker because it kind of makes it go
faster yeah it cuts the time in half
otherwise without
otherwise it's going to take you about
four or five hours
it's a texture thing so we follow that
like a half a cup of yellow onion
i use carter ben kroger brand real bacon
bits
i love the bacon
um i use about a teaspoon of garlic
minced garlic you can also get that
and then i have
a mixture of seasonal salt garlic salt
and onion powder
but i like to just put that on top
and then give it a stir i'll get your
door yeah i just use a splash of oil
what i love about recipes like this is
there's this there's not a lot of work
that goes into it it's just a lot of
time and a lot of a lot of love right
absolutely
you gotta have a passion for it and
that's one thing it's a blessing that
i've had the opportunity to do that i
also use you gotta cook it down
chicken broth okay so pour that in the
consistency is what you're looking for
is to make sure that you have plenty of
liquids in this
and you can use chicken broth and water
about four cups of water is as well so
okay um pour that in
and
we'll give it a stir give it a stir this
is the most important ingredient it is
uh white distilled vinegar get about a
half cup of that so bring it to a simmer
turn the heat to low put the lid on it
and then four hours later you've got
voila we've got some delicious collard
greens let's see how they turned out
now does your family love this stuff
they do i actually keep
bags in the freezer so they have them
available whenever they want them
awesome they freeze very well you can
find all these ingredients at your local
smiths thank you so much for watching
thank you for shopping we'll see you
next time thank you uh thanks so much
for being with me it's been an honor
thank you all right bye bye everybody
thank you to smith's food and drug for
sponsoring this segment make sure to
visit their website for more information
it's right there on your screen mercedes
over to you